Cay and I are going to help make sure you get BlueJ and the course code
installed and downloaded. Installing BlueJ will have two main parts, installing
Java and installing BlueJ. You might not notice this part if you are on a Mac.
There are links below that will help guide you. There are written installation
instructions and some videos of the installation process. You'll need to pick
the right instructions for your operating system, Mac or Windows. If you can't
get BlueJ running, it's not your fault. It just means your computer's set up
differently from ours. We can help. Post your questions on the forums. Below
this video, there's a section called discussions. You can read other people's
questions and answer, or you can ask a question yourself. When you're asking a
question, give us as much information about what you did and what the result
was, as you can. The more you tell us, the clearer our advice will be. Once
you've successfully installed BlueJ, open BlueJ and go to the Help menu. Select
About or Copyright, whichever one you see. Who's the first contributor on the
team? In other words, what's the first name that comes up?